exploite en France 120 médicaments et
vaccins ce qui correspond à 350 et une
présentation et environ 90% de ces
produits sont des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur c'est-à-dire les
thèmes font l'objet comme la loi le
prévoit de plantes gestion des pénuries
PGP qui sont communiqués à NSM
nous suivons également avec attention
nos autres produits qui ne rentrent pas
dans cette catégorie
nos médicaments permettent de traiter un
grand nombre de pathologies dont des
arts thérapeutiques aussi différentes
que l'immunologie le l'oncologie la
virologie les vaccins les maladies rares
et la médecine
en termes de produits en cours de
développement
notre pipeline comprend à ce jour 110
programmes de recherche dans 23
programmes en phase 3 et 16 programmes
en phase d'enregistrement
près de 9000 patients français étaient
inclus en 2021 dans nos essais cliniques
en France
alors en termes de production
Pfizer dispose de 36 sites de
fabrication en propre localisé en Europe
en Amérique du Nord
Amérique du Sud Afrique du Nord
Moyen-Orient
Océanie et Asie
notre chaîne d'approvisionnement et de
production comprend également plus de
315 sites externes répartis dans 44 pays
dont 14 pays européens
alors un point très important maintenant
notre entreprise est très peu dépendante
de la Chine et de l'Inde et je
souhaiterais souligné ce point même si
notre même si nous disposons
d'infrastructures importantes dans ces
dpi les trois quarts de la production de
médicaments réalisés en Chine et en Inde
sont destinées à l'approvisionnement des
marchés chinois et indiens
la production en provenance de Chine et
dinde ne représente pas plus de 0 points
6% de nos médicaments distribués en
France 0.6%
d'ailleurs
98% de nos médicaments distribués en
France sont fabriqués en Europe